alles daran setzen wir einen glaube ich
will nicht mehr drauf machen da sitzen
wir also und heute bin ich den nächsten
logischen schritt gegangen nachdem wir
alles gesund dass viele kamen keine
sorge wir können auch noch mal so das
beruhigt recht 400.000 deutete jetzt
jedes mal angucken beruhigt wir
sodastream wieder
wir haben nämlich einen entsafter
besorgt hat mich 160 euro gekostet von
letzten video läuft wir sparen sich den
richtigen gegner meister holt jetzt habe
hier 1100 mehr käufer entfährt das ist
mir persönlich relativ richtig bei der
sache
ich habe nicht nur vor obst zu entsagen
damit ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich
schon vorstellen es ist ein
zentrifugalen entsafter das heißt dass
arbeite mit der kraft des universums und
damit den saft benutzen wird nichts zu
suchen
warum bringen wir das noch mal bei mir
baualter junge wie es der spielverein
das noch gut vereint beispielsweise
er mag es wenn da was reinkommt um die
ohren fliegt nämlich sterben hier nur
damit sie überhaupt nichts rein was bei
der wm die sachen machen
dann musste es ja auch jeden mal
ausspielen das ist schon klar bist du
zufrieden dass wir das hier bei dir
wieder mal machen mit aber wenn bei euch
nicht gebohrt worden wäre dann wären wir
auch immer bei dir gewesen heute will
ich ganz ehrlich das stellt aber
unterlagen
jetzt hofft der eine also das kann im
prinzip ist es doch ein bisschen weniger
alles sagt er also dass wir brauchen
aber gläsern oder ja ich will das alles
vorbereitet leute du darfst wie immer
aus der magischen ja ich mag es bin ganz
ehrlich irgendwie fahrten kritisch man
ich glaube dass wir sehr sehr gut so
weil ich hier schon so krass wie die
chips nicht für die gummibärchen jedoch
nicht das packt legt jedoch allerdings
ein bisschen wasser geht das auf jeden
fall also ich glaube da ist wenn ich
mache stufe 1
machen wir weiter mit der nächsten sagte
das sagt nicht geglaubt zumal wie das
aussieht hat ist so schnell heiß
geworden vielleicht ja das ist richtig
war das gummibärchen wasser drin war
der test ist erstklassig schmeckt lecker
ich weiß ist das schönste was man mit
der maschine zu beginn machen wir nie
dann beginnen auch hart rechner muss man
jedoch kam halt auf leute und ich
dazwischen wir testen
wir machen das für euch das ist ja das
ist ja nimmt schon zu genüge sagt jan
wissenschaftlich vor macht man das ja
nicht zu sparen
nach diesem tollen erfolg würde ich
sagen wenn wir uns direkt der nächsten
sache wie ich glaube das funktioniert
gut das war ein kleiner in berlin gibt
es gesagt habe ich noch nie in
irgendeiner supermarkt gesehen also da
das wird jetzt relativ einfach
funktionieren
diese geräusche meine wortwahl
heinz hat sie wieder zurückkommen
oh mein gott
alter
und die kürzlich jetzt ganz gedacht
immer wieder früh über ja
[Musik]
novi sad ist nicht nur ein beruf ist
vorbei
bisher konnte das ja kein nein
besorgt
der
wie einfach wieder einfach so viel
die 14-jährige sind jedem total
begeistert sind von so einem entsafter
es ist wirklich geil
also man muss sagen da ist nichts mit
drin also nicht mal die kerne sind drin
oder vorweg gesagt ja es hat so ein
bisschen - so bietet ist so dick ist uns
zudem in ihrem persönlichen geschmack
teenager da schmeckt richtig crazy
lecker ja er übe geil und hat total
cremig also das so cremig oder sonst was
drin doch noch gut welche der halbe kopf
ist die relative die ich da rein
gestellt
das wissen dass hermann was wir mit dem
ganzen ich sage das ist einer von zwei
gold race okay okay kann man einfach mal
das gleiche dann geht auch noch die
nächste sache fand ich schon bald muss
ich ehrlich sagen wir haben aber auch
auf andere coole sachen also du bist
immer so am jüngsten augen führen drei
sachen die man sonst ja am wochenende
doktor das kann ich mir nächstes ins akh
verwickelt das sieht gegen davos
dafür habe ich aber dass hier nur das
funktioniert so ein kinderkino sheikh in
30 sekunden verklagt hat aber nicht etwa
mit lecker
wir wollen nicht gefrühstückt und das
ist keine gute idee das mit den ganzen
günstig fährt jetzt nummer zwei
aha
die masse
noch am mittag
ja
das friedensdorf
nach trägem einer
dass weihnachten
ja
unser entlastete swallow beziehungsweise
wayne oreste außenwänden darf damit raus
gespielt wenn er sagte aus dem interesse
ich bin sehr gespannt es ist ein sehr
kostspieliger prozess merke ich an der
stelle auf jeden fall schon weil das
waren jetzt zwei packen breno mit ist
leicht wird und wo wir komplett alter
also ich mich ganz ehrlich sagen ich
glaube mixa würde es immer noch besser
passt dann nämlich ein bisschen wieder
von einem renault als will das sind
abfalls entgegen aber du hast ganz
leicht einen ganz leichten geschmack ja
aber das find ich geil dass er sich dass
er nur so leicht ist also der mini
stückchen bin grade dem meeting ich rufe
dir sofort ein video gehört hast das
meeting bist ja jetzt ist natürlich
wichtig nämlich gerade selber auf bei
mensa vom kinder jeden alters ist ich
hab gerade keine zeit zum telefonieren
das war auf jeden fall wieder zehn von
zehn der move dass ich das gerade
ausgeschüttet habe ja gerade freien in
die matte das normalste körper ohne
schale wird doch ja auch mit schade klar
so funktioniert das ding ja ich finde
alle comedy hätte zumindest die stars
müssen wahrscheinlich ja es war so war
es ist so wahnsinnig und dann wieder
normal und dann wieder
normale pcs der halt wahrscheinlich
müssen wir wirklich die schalen waschen
vielleicht doch die sind somit wachse
gesprüht oder so bisschen war es hat
noch keinen umgebracht
vom verein ja
neu
was ist los
kommt bestimmt ist einfach werbung
machen für dein produkt und dann so ein
buch ist einfach beim anlauf sagte
rösler
darauf macht das alter jetzt habe ich
aber auch schlicht bock auf die groß wie
wie kommt man an die werbefläche ist das
falsch gewesen weil ich mich vielleicht
sollte man nur früchte mit schade machen
und bei dem man noch die schale mit ist
zum beispiel äpfel kirche geht das wir
werden herausfinden willst oder unsere
mägen heute abend im laufe des tages
nicht aber durch eine ganz gestörte
farben
ich hab einfach crazy dauer wieder das
ist sehr bitter wenn so sollte man sich
nehmen sind wieder unfassbar cremig war
das ist wirklich nett dass eine klare 0
day date von bei mir
das ist so bitter und rand sich dadurch
wie den wachs also wirklich so hinten im
rachen oder so offiziers abgelagert
vielleicht werden wird aber auch einfach
nur qualitativ hochwertige wagst du
früchtchen wenn man die komponente von
der schale ausblendet wie man ja unter
umständen als meinen fehler auslegen
könnte unter umständen eigentlich sagen
wir mal so es wäre sehr weit weg geholt
es wäre schon leckie weitergeht wird
sagen vorher zur sache tut das auch
manchmal ziehen bin mir relativ sicher
dass eine sache dran kommen wird die 3
die masse ich nehme doch dass ich will
wissen was ist das ist mal was heute
natürlich nicht mehr drin bleibt mainz
05 war einfach nur wasser sind ist
allerdings das ist noch können dass wir
noch nie
das ist da ich will nur sagen dass hier
oben haben wir ein bisschen ab jetzt
kapitalien wir haben oben abgeschnitten
sieht man gar nicht mit dass nicht das
wollen wir eigentlich auch eher sagen
aber es ist das trocknen von uns lieb
ist richtig bin ich wirklich bin dann
bin ich sehr gespannt wie das ärgert
mich dass die latte
er ist so geil
ich glaube es gab schon ein bisschen an
seinem leben gekommen es liegt so ein
bisschen wie verbrannt mit orangen sagt
gerade also sehr lecker es riecht schon
sehr appetitlich
wir probieren jetzt unseren charakter
sagt oder ok ja es riecht ein bisschen
bienen fleischmarkt sehe ich jetzt diese
weise wie fleischmann food court im
kaufhaus jetzt so ganz viele gerüche
wenn ja j mit sushi mit irgendeinem
smoothie stand oder auch meiner rede
nicht so mit je schmidt gehört ist
vielleicht auch das wäre ja wow wo hatte
eine hässliche frucht bei den geschmack
macht keinen sinn das hat keinen
sauberen 8 es ist aber auch nicht süß es
ist aber auch nicht irgendwie das ist
nicht süß
ja es ist süß als das schmeckt wie pure
honig beim 1 aber ich hab auch keine
geschmacks
ich finde das ist eine ganz komische
süßlich findet somit gar nicht gewohnt
hat ist nämlich aber ich finds nicht ist
hat so einen ganz großen abgang köhlers
so zuckerwatte saft für mich das
zuckerersatz das schmeckt ihr sohn nicht
zucker zucker wie sony heute wieder
mittel schwimmt das nur die süße habe
das aber so ganz viel davon als wenn du
so 10 tabletten süßmittel so in deinem
und gleichzeitig tust das kriegt von mir
für den überraschungsfaktor den
doppelten dave boris manieren doppelter
day auch weil es den geschmack verliert
findet aber halt nicht schlecht schon
wieder was find of the day für euch ist
willkommen zur allerletzten sache ich
weiß ja was es ist wird unglaublich
schön
ja das wird funktionieren das wird
wahrscheinlich bis guten bringen das
hinter uns
das war kurzer prozess da ist er also
das getränk wird niemals existieren
sollte der sandwich gurken wie keiner
seiner macht hätte ich auch eigentlich
ziemlich dafür muss ich sagen ich schon
und das ding jetzt wir drehen jetzt im
video was tatsächlich sehr lecker wird
den ständigen so ein lieblingsessen
vielfältig kanal und das ist das einzige
was mich gerade ein bisschen am leben
hält
einzig will hier würden tage wenn das
jetzt nur überraschung ist 50 grad das
bleibt natürlich ein bisschen die tränen
in die augen wie auch das volk gegen
ekelhaft aber wieso ist es trotzdem
cremig frage warum macht dieses gerät
alles cremig würzig nun wieder zu hause
ist und da dein café nimmst dann bitte
kaffee einfach noch mal drückt aus und
gibt es auch der komiker wird ja
vielleicht beim nächsten mal leute wir
sehen uns ist mal wieder komplett heraus
dass gerne reichler immer schwerer abo
dabei max dieses jahr eine million
man wolle jetzt